et là vous le voyez se désamarrer
maintenant que l'équipage du soyuz ms-20 est officiellement sur
le chemin du retour, ils sont arrivés aux
jours de rotation ou 12 jours vivant à bord du
complexe en orbite et
je suis prêt pour le deuxième séparé
mais deux
à la fin
le  aperçu des membres de l'équipage qui, une fois de
plus, on nous dit qu'ils ont eu eu un
coup de feu plus tôt sur l'équipage extrait
du soyuz qui ressemble à euh
alexander misurkin là le commandant
de euh la euh la capsule soyuz et
c'est parti
il y a un deuxième membre d'équipage qui sort
qui ressemble à yasakumazewa
pour ce voyage,
un autre prend
également des vêtements
de l'autre et il y a notre troisième
membre d'équipage jose
hirano extrait du soyuz dans cette
rediffusion de la vidéo qui a été tournée il y a quelques
minutes à peine
oh